مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في رموز زلمه من قناه
الجزيره افادت وكاله رويترز انها بريطانيا
وتزويده اوكرانيا بدبابات لاول مره من اجل
القوات الروسيه ونقلت الوكاله عن تقارير
ان المناقشات جاريه منذ اسابيع بشان تسليم
10 دبابات بريطانيه من طرازات تشالنجر 2
لاوكرانيا
الاسلحه الغربيه لاوكرانيا لن تكون قادره
على تغيير اي شيء بشكل جذري وفي موضوع اخر
قال لكريم لانه لا صحه للمزاعم عن موجه
جديده من التعبئه الجزئيه في روسيا
قال القوات الروسيه انها تحرز تقدم من على
محور باخ موت في مقاطعه دونيه قال الجيش
الاوكراني ان الجيش الروسي قصف مدينه
سوليدار وشلف 22 هجومات في محاوله اقتحام
المدينه
اعتمد مجلس الامن الدولي قرارا يمدد العمل
باليه ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه عبر
الحدود الى سوريا لمده سته اشهر يسمح
القرار بادخال المساعدات الانسانيه عبر
معبر باب الهوى على الحدود مع تركيا دون
اذن من النظام السوري
رجعت يا قالت منظمه منسقوا استجابه سوريا
ان اعداد المحتاجين الى مساعدات الانسانيه
في سوريا تجاوزت 15 مليون نسمه وهو رقم
الاعلام الاثنين 10 عاما
انهت الاطراف الموقع على الاتفاق الايطالي
السياسي في السودان اليوم الثاني من
المناقشات وقال المتحدث باسم عمليه
السياسيه في السودان خالد عمر يوسف ان
النقاشات مع القوه الرافضه الاتفاق
الايطالي مستمره لتضمنها في المرحله
النهائيه للعمليه السياسيه
من جهه قال السفير النرويجي في السودان
ممثل الوساطه الدوليه اندروس في مقابله مع
الجزيره النووي يؤمن ان الجيش السوداني
سينفذ تعهداته ويعود الى فقناسه
تعهد الرئيس البرازيلي الاولى دا سيلفا
بملاحقه من سماهم ممولي التحركات
الانقلابيه وكشف ان اجهزه الامن اعتقلت
الفا وخمسمائه على ذمه التحقيق في
اقتحاماتي مراكز السلطه في العاصمه
البرازيليه وصفا رئيس البرازيلي اجتماع
حكام الولايات من مختلف الاحزاب في
العاصمه البرازيليه دليلا على قدره
البرازيليين على الوحده من اجل
الديمقراطيه
[تصفيق]
فضت الشرطه والبرازيليه اعتصاما لانصار
الرئيس الاسبق جيل بورسنارو قرب ووزاره
الدفاع واستدعت مزيدا من القوات الاحتواء
انصاره في العاصمه وذلك غدا تقتحام مناصري
الرئيس السابق مقر حكوميه احتجاجا على
تنصيب الرئيس المنتخب الاولى دا سيلفا
ووصفاه ورئيس المحكمه العليا والكونجرس
الاقتحامات بالانقلاب والعمل الارهابي وقد
استانف مهامه في القصر الرئاسي في هذه
الاثناء ان نقل الرئيس السابق جير بول
سينارو الى مستشفى
اعرب الرئيس الامريكي نظيره البرازيليه
الاولى الصلبه في اتصال هاتفي دعم
الولايات المتحده الثابت للديمقراطيه في
البرازيل
ونتيجه الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي فاز بها
لولدي السلفاوس واستنكر الرئيس الاعمال
العنف والهجوم على المؤسسات الديمقراطيه
البرازيليه والتداول السلميه للسلطه
مشاهده
[موسيقى]